they say that the first impression is
the last impression but what if
everything after that first impression
sucks these Infamous flicks speak
viewers interest only to drop the ball
mere moments later the third Austin
Powers installment starts off with such
a bang that it's a shame the rest of the
movie can't live up to it the opening
set piece is an over-the-top action
parody of Austin himself with none other
than Tom Cruise donning the shagalicious
secret agent's thick glasses and 60s
threats Kevin Spacey shows up as Dr Evil
Danny DeVito plays mini me and Gwyneth
Paltrow stars as Austin's love interest
and is revealed to be directed by none
other than Steven Spielberg who responds
to Austin's criticisms of the sequence
by holding up one of his three Oscars it
all ends with an elaborate dance number
over the opening credits featuring
further cameos by Quincy Jones and
Britney Spears as a femme bot it's a
testament to the franchise's popularity
at the time that so many a-listers
volunteered their talents for just a few
minutes very shagadelic baby yeah a
weird amalgamation of Goldfinger and
Indiana Jones in the Last Crusade the
film finds Austin Bowers traveling back
in time to rescue his kidnapped father
British secret agent Nigel powers from
Dr Evil when he lands in 1975 Powers
teams up with American agent Foxy
Cleopatra played by none other than
Beyonce to keep Dr Evil from taking over
the world with Goldmember a Dutch super
villain with peeling skin and golden
genitals although the movie has its fair
share of laughs the spark from the first
two is missing and the critical reaction
reflects that
the success of Who Framed Roger Rabbit
inspired animation Legend Ralph bakshi
to try his hand at aversion for adults
unfortunately the man who made cartoons
x-rated with Fritz the Cat had lost some
of his Edge by the time cool world came
around he seemed to have lost some of
his skills as a filmmaker as well since
the live action and animated elements
rarely seem to be existing within the
same frame the film begins in 1940s Las
Vegas where World War II vet Frank
Harris is somehow teleported into the
Animated Universe of cool world
eventually becoming a police detective
Flash Forward to 1992 when animator Jack
deebs is released from a 10-year prison
sentence while behind bars he created
the successful comic strip cool world
based on weird dreams he'd been having
Jack is sucked into the animated realm
where he's seduced by his cartoon
creation Hollywood Holly wants to become
a real woman by Sleeping with Jack even
though sex between Doodles and noids is
strictly forbidden although cool world
has developed a bit of a cult following
it was universally panned by critics
when it was first released few people
found much of anything to like about it
especially when held up against the near
seamless integration of animation and
live action in Who Framed Roger Rabbit
say what you will about Fast and Furious
the critically maligned 4th entry in the
long-running franchise but it features a
banger of an opening chase scene a bit
of a retcon reset after Tokyo Drift it
begins in the Dominican Republic where
Dominic Toretto is still hiding out
after the events of the first film cause
him to flee LA with the help of his
girlfriend Letty and his pal Han Dom
hijacks a couple of fuel tankers by
racing alongside them in his muscle car
it's a high octane sequence that shows
off director Justin Lin's talent for
staging the kind of elaborate action set
pieces that became the series trademark
but Things Fall Apart quickly when Dom
returns to Los Angeles to avenge letty's
supposed death although it's fun to see
diesel reunite with Paul Walker as
former cop Brian O'Connor the Duelist
plot to take down a drug kingpin
inspires few fireworks admittedly The
Fast and Furious series had yet to find
its footing by the time this film came
along it wasn't until the next
installment Fast Five that they ditched
the formula and shifted the focus
towards a found family of globetrotting
crime Fighters you can see elements of
the direction the franchise would take
in parts of this movie for better in for
worse but nothing linen company come up
with can top The hair-raising Heist
scene that kicks things off
overwhelming anticipation for a sequel
to The Silence of the Lambs quickly
dissipated the moment Thomas Harris's
novel Hannibal was released so shocking
and lurid was the book's violence that
director Jonathan Demi star Jody Foster
and screenwriter Ted Talley all of whom
won Oscars for Silence of the Lambs
declined to return for this follow-up
only Hannibal Lecter himself fellow
Oscar winner Anthony Hopkins agreed to
appear with Ridley Scott Julianne Moore
David Mamet and Steven's alien taking up
directing acting and writing duties
respectively are you confused this being
a Ridley Scott movie Hannibal is nothing
if not beautiful to look at even when
the content makes you want to look away
and indeed there are many moments when
the sheer craft alone may trick you into
thinking you're watching a masterpiece
from the opening sequence when the
horribly disfigured Mason Berger played
by an uncredited Gary Oldman quizzes
prison guard Barney as to Hannibal's
whereabouts Scott creates a feeling of
dread and unease aided by John
Matheson's Moody cinematography Hans
Zimmer's Eerie score and Nora Spencer's
elaborate production design as the film
progresses however you can't help but
sense some of the Silence of the Lamb's
magic is missing part of the problem is
Moore's casting as Clary Starling the
FBI agent tracking Lecter down as he
eats his way through Europe as great of
an actress as she is she can't erase our
memories of Foster's iconic performance
yet critics saved their harshest
criticisms for the movie's violence
which was still brutal even with massive
deviations from the book while League's
above the recent Jurassic World Series
the Lost World Jurassic Park was
nevertheless seen as a major come down
from its predecessor it's easy to
understand why Steven Spielberg would
want to make a sequel to his monster
1993 hit and individual sequences remind
us of his skills both as a visual
Storyteller and as an action filmmaker
the film's opening is particularly
strong a vacationing British family
decides to dock their yacht on the
remote island of Isla sorna not knowing
it's home to some of those genetically
engineered dinosaurs their daughter
wanders off and is greeted by what
appears to be your friendly
compsignathus but their interaction
turns dangerous when an entire flock of
the tiny Predators attacks her he
survives fortunately but that doesn't
make the experience any less terrifying
once Dr Ian Malcolm travels to the
island at the behest of Dr John Hammond
however the Lost World proves that
there's really no good way to make a
Jurassic Park sequel even though we got
four more attempts at doing just that
while the dinosaurs inspired awe and
wonder in the first film here they're
seen only as monsters to run away from
given Spielberg's directorial Talent
those Chase sequences are thrilling yet
as critics pointed out the people doing
the running away are little more than
Dino food aside from Pete possible
thwaite's entertaining turn as the Big
Game Hunter who's come to the island in
search of exciting new prey trick is
to get him
to come where we want him
stop motion director Henry Selleck
created eye-popping worlds in his
animated films The Nightmare Before
Christmas and Coraline and the same is
true of Monkeybone unfortunately the
characters he creates in this
live-action animation hybrid aren't
nearly as compelling as their
surroundings part of the problem is
Monkeybone himself as voiced by John
Turturro he's a cartoon creation of
animators to mili portrayed by living
legend Brendan Fraser who finds himself
tormented by the claymation primate when
a car accident puts him in a coma while
trapped in the Bizarro realm of his
imagination Stu links up with monkey
bone to try and get back to his fiancee
only to find out the little stinker
plans to use his body as a way to enter
the human world before Stu's accident
we're treated to a glimpse of monkey
bone as an animated series which is set
to make him a very rich man although the
raunchy cartoon is funny in short form
we soon realize that a little bit of
monkey bone goes a long way especially
when he inhabits Fraser's body things
liven up a little when stew in an
attempt to reclaim his life jumps into
the body of a recently deceased organ
donor played by the hilarious Chris
Katan who keeps spilling his Parts all
over town if the middle section were as
good as the beginning and the end monkey
bone might have turned out to be some
kind of Bonkers Masterpiece as it stands
however it's an ambitious curio one that
appalled critics and scared away
audiences Disney's association with the
Wizard of Oz goes all the way back to
the 1930s when Walt wanted to turn the
book into an animated follow-up to Snow
White and the Seven Dwarfs but the
estate of el Frank bomb had already sold
the rights to Samuel Goldwyn who in turn
sold them to Louis B Mayer and the rest
is history that didn't stop Disney
Studios from trying to make their own
version of the classic book series
including the surprisingly dark Return
to Oz culminating in the critically
maligned Oz the Great and Powerful stop
you're hurting him
foreign
[Applause]
y it stars James Franco as Oscar Diggs a
traveling circus magician and con man
who's plucked out of Kansas by a tornado
and plopped down in the magical land of
Oz the locals think Oscar is a great
wizard who's come to save them but she
decides to use for his financial gain
his magical abilities come under
scrutiny from three witches Theodora
evanora and Glinda each of whom hopes to
employ him in their fight for control of
Oz copyright laws kept Raymond from
using some of the most iconic characters
in imagery from the 1939 Wizard of Oz
including Dorothy's ruby red slippers
the beginning of his film which follows
Oscar's origins in Kansas is a callback
to the original shot in Black and White
Academy ratio it's so good it makes you
wish she had the rights to make an
official prequel rather than well
whatever the heck this movie turned out
to be Tim Burton had firmly established
himself as one of Hollywood's most
visually inventive filmmakers by the
time he took a crack at remaking Planet
of the Apes unlike the most recent
Trilogy which employed motion capture
CGI to turn humans into Apes the
director used practical makeup effects
courtesy of Rick Baker and this being a
Tim Burton film you know the art
direction is going to be similarly
dazzling if the screenplay were up to
that same level of craft there might
have really been something here Hope
Springs Eternal when the film opens as
astronaut Leo Davidson crash lands on a
mysterious planet where humans are
enslaved in Apes Reigns Supreme there's
a goofy charm to Mark Wahlberg's
performance as a Spaceman who goes into
orbit to save his partner a chimpanzee
named Pericles only to find himself
captured by intellectually Advanced
primates the eight performances by Tim
Roth Helena Bonham Carter Michael Clark
Duncan and Paul Giamatti are fully
committed despite being hidden under
pounds of makeup and not for nothing but
there are also some impressive action
sequences yet as the film progresses you
get the sinking feeling that the three
credited screenwriters William Broyles
Jr Lawrence Connor and Mark Rosenthal
didn't know exactly what tone to strike
worst of all the customary twist ending
raises more questions than it answers
the finished product was a critical
disaster that failed to relaunch a
franchise ice and featured well this
foreign
Moore's final outing as James Bond and A
View to a Kill was a real low point for
the series earning some of the
franchise's worst reviews yet even the
worst 007 outing still has a great
opening sequence albeit one with a very
noticeable stun double for more who at
57 was starting to show his age bond is
dispatched to Siberia to retrieve a
microchip from a fallen agent when he's
discovered by the bad guys he has to
evade them by sledding down the icy
Mountain first on skis then on a
snowmobile and finally on a makeshift
snowboard all while accompanied by The
Beach Boys classic California Girls
after blowing up the helicopter that's
been chasing him Bond enters a hidden
submarine and gets cozy with a beautiful
Submariner and of course there's the
opening credits sequence set to Duran
Duran's theme song aptly titled A View
to a Kill Bon later finds out the
microchipped is a product of Zorn
Industries led by the villainous Max
zorin played by Christopher Walken doing
his best bad guy act zorin has some
nefarious scheme to become the world's
leading microchip manufacturer by wiping
out Silicon Valley aided by his hen
Mayday by this point in Moore's run the
series had become so campy and
lightweight that it was difficult to
take anything seriously although Die
Hard fans will still stick up for this
film it was clear that a massive reset
was necessary to keep the franchise
alive